five it can be helpful or not helpful
okay okay so go ahead our helpful vice
with Bobby
kalila at Jamie Kennedy hello tiger
belly I'm 30 years old and my parents
are still married but they had been
separated for three years
my parents were moving to Arizona which
where I live four years ago from Miami
Florida once moved my father started
acting distance distant and kept going
back to Miami singing was to finish some
work after a few months of this he told
my mother you wanted some space and
didn't feel the same way about her they
had been married 29 years turns out he
was seeing another woman and still sees
her but is also still married to my
mother my mom hopes that he will come
back because she is very religious
praying that he will change my father
has not spoken to neither my sister or I
since he announced a separation from my
mother my question is how do I approach
my father and confront him with all my
feelings about stringing my mom along
not talking to the kids and how hurt we
all feel Thank You Vanessa
her dad has a whole second life yeah and
still married to the mother but you took
off he doesn't talk to anybody I live in
this other life in Miami
yeah wait so how long has he been out of
her life they've been separated for
three years but she doesn't say how long
he's been going back to Miami
no but he's obviously still giving the
mom hope that they're gonna defer a
reconciliation by not getting divorced
the mom's got it the mom here's the
advice the mom's gotta you can't control
the mom right he can't control another
person so if the mom wants to live the
dream that's what she's gonna do it's
the moms too mom's got to get out of it
yeah I think that here on to the right
point I think that if he is not
communicating and he she is being
dragged along she has to let go she has
to end it and he's got to cut the guy on
your life so does Vanessa talk then
instead of talking to her father I just
talk to her mom yeah because shoot that
day I obviously have communication
mm-hmm sukkah mom we gotta get you to
detach he's a piece of [ __ ] right I'm
sure there's a love there use your dad
you know but and you can deal with your
your resentments and all that stuff
later but I think that once
there's you know you know a lawful
separation a divorce and then you let
some time pass you know go to therapy
and deal with it but you know it's not
you the mom is getting hurt she has to
let go she has to be free of it yeah she
has to find her own life what do you
think Dave yeah if I will know if I was
the dog no not that close to home did
you do wrong no but I'm just saying I
would if I were her I would absolutely
speak to the dad and I think that he
probably isn't aware of all the hurt
that he's causing if no one's telling
him and if he's if I if I have two kids
and let's say we had two kids together
yeah right our kids are grown Georgian
rice hmm
what your kids are Georgia Bryce yeah
Georgia brought some of my kids all
right and III meet you know mean some
girl in North Carolina right and I cut
off communication with my two sons and
you four years right I know you know
what I'm doing mm-hmm yes and I'm
stringing you along because I still
there still love there you know yeah and
I'm living in I still feel bad but I'm
still getting a piece of both a little
bit you have to end it you have to end
it yeah that's true but it's not going
to stop if one of our kids decided that
they wanted to give you a piece of their
mind I think that you ought to hear it
I'm not this is a scenario I don't know
why you're [ __ ] Georgia okay if I
said that look like that kill myself
teachers call right maybe him he's fine
he's a son I like Wow yeah okay
it's called unhelpful advice
[Music]